-My first guest tonight
is an Emmy- and
Golden Globe-winning actress.
She stars in and executive
produces "The Morning Show."
Season two of the show is out on
Apple TV+ starting today.
Please welcome Jennifer Aniston!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah!
That's what I'm talking about!
Ha ha!
Ohh, man!
Come on. Now, look at --
Jennifer, you're getting --
-Hi, everybody.
-You're getting, like,
a standing ovation
through the Zoom.
-I am?
-Yes, people love you!
We love you.
Thank you for coming back.
Please.
-I so wish I was there in that
room with you right now.
I can't tell you.
I miss New York.
I miss your face.
-Oh, good. We miss you.
New York City misses you.
I know you're from here.
You grew up here.
-Yeah.
-Did you always want to be
an actress as a kid?
-Pretty much.
Yeah, I think I was --
You know, I did plays --
little plays.
I went to a Waldorf school,
Rudolf Steiner School
on 79th Street.
And, yeah, I was very --
And my dad obviously is an
actor, still, on a soap opera.
-Yeah, of course.
-So yeah, pretty young
I got that bug.
-Yeah. And when did you feel
like you finally made it?
-Oh, when did I finally make it?
Well, you know,
Bob's Big Boy commercial.
-Wow.
-That's when I finally --
[ Laughter ]
But you have to understand,
I auditioned a lot,
and I never --
I just couldn't get arrested.
And it was Bob's Big Boy.
That was my first job.
And I thought,
"Wow, I have arrived."
-Were you --
Are you good at auditions?
-No!
-I'm terrible.
-Terrible. Awful.
-I am -- I did one
commercial audition once
where I was supposed to be
a bike messenger.
And I showed up
for the audition, and everyone
was dressed as a bike messenger.
And I had no -- I had like two
outfits in my whole closet.
I'm like, "You have an extra
bike messenger outfit?"
Like, what?
-Yeah.
-Right before I was supposed
to do it, he goes,
"You're out of breath.
You have to deliver this
whatever it was."
And I go, "Uh-huh."
And he goes, "So you're sweaty."
And he took out a water bottle
and he sprayed me in the face
with water.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, look at you now.
-That's exactly --
Look at us now.
Jinx!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jinx.
-Jinx.
-From that to winning an Emmy
on "Friends."
And, also, speaking of Emmys,
this weekend is the Emmys,
and you're nominated
for "Friends" again.
Isn't that interesting?
For the reunion.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know.
-That's kind of cool.
-17 years -- 17 years later.
Isn't that crazy?
-I loved it.
-It's so wild.
-I loved the reunion.
I thought it was cool.
I just thought that --
I loved that everyone
got together.
I was so emotional.
-Thanks.
-I could just imagine
what you guys were like.
But I was watching like -- whew!
-Yeah.
-Every time everyone would bring
up the thing, I would get all --
Just watching it
was just emotional and great.
I loved it.
-It was emotional.
-Thanks for doing that.
-It really was.
We did it for you, Jimmy.
It was --
-I know. Thank you.
I appreciate that.
Oh, you know what was --
-You're welcome.
-What was great, right after
that came out for about --
maybe about eight hours,
there was a rumor
that you and David Schwimmer
were dating.
And I thought that was awesome.
-That was a rumor.
That window -- we shut that
one down pretty quickly.
[ Laughter ]
-The world got excited there.
-They just wanted it so bad.
They believe
so much in Ross and Rachel.
I mean, didn't you have
all of those --
-Yeah.
-For me, it was like
Luke and Laura
on "General Hospital."
-Ohh!
-Or, you know,
"Joanie Loves Chachi."
-Oh, imagine if Luke and Laura
really da--
That would be amazing.
I love Luke and Laura.
-I know.
And I --
It made me so sad.
And, you know, when I was a kid,
I would record,
because we didn't have VCR --
We just didn't have a VCR.
-Yeah.
-"Joanie Loves Chachi"
or "Happy Days"
or all of those shows,
"Laverne and Shirley,"
on a tape recorder.
Like a -- Like a --
-Yeah.
-Like, stick it into a...
-I would do that.
-...tape deck,
and I would hit record.
And I would listen to the shows
as I went to bed.
-That's wild.
I would do that
with "Saturday Night Live."
I would tape it,
and then I would, like,
listen to them back.
I would lip sync, like,
Steve Martin or Richard Pryor,
and just do all that
in my bedroom.
That was, like, the thing.
Because we -- there was no VCR.
There was nothing to tape.
-No.
-That's wild.
-But there you go.
See? Again, and look at you,
where you ended up.
And look where --
-Look at you. Look at us.
Come on. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is all early years.
You know, by the way,
I was a bike messenger.
When you say you auditioned
for a bike --
Did I ever tell you that?
-You were a bike messenger?
-I was a bike messenger
for a day in New York City.
[ Laughter ]
-That counts.
-I worked at this -- I worked
at an advertising agency
after school.
My mom actually worked there.
So I would, to make extra money,
I would do the odd jobs.
And then, one day,
their bike messenger was not --
just didn't show up.
And they were like,
"Can you ride a bike?"
And I was like,
"Yeah, I can ride a bike."
-It's a gig.
-Now, mind you,
in Central Park,
I can ride a bike.
I mean...
-On the street...
-...with soft areas to land.
[ Laughter ]
But so I just boldly said yes.
And they gave me this bag,
and they put
all these cylinders in this bag.
And, oh, it was just
not a great --
-Cylinders like Mike Brady?
Like, plans?
Like, those tubes?
-Yeah, and they were sealed.
You'd have to deliver
to the wherever.
I mean, in my brain,
I don't know how I survived
the day because it was --
to be on Fifth Avenue
with traffic
and all that I was holding,
and then I think I might have
gotten into a cab
just to finish the day.
[ Laughter ]
-You were a bike messenger.
You made sure it got there.
That's all that matters.
-I just had to get it there.
So I -- I don't know
what happened to the bike.
-You delivered.
-It's all a blur.
-I wanted to reach out to you
because I was watching
"The Morning Show."
I loved it, by the way,
season one.
You were fantastic.
-Thank you.
-Reese Witherspoon is fantastic.
The show's great.
-Thanks.
-But there was a scene with you
and Billy Crudup
where you were both singing...
♪ No one's gonna harm you,
not while -- ♪
-Yes!
-I love that scene.
-Sondheim.
-Dude, that was
my favorite scene.
And it's Broadway week here
at our show.
Would you ever do
a Broadway show?
-I would love to do
a Broadway show in my --
[ Cheers and applause ]
In my head, it sounds like --
What? What?
Really?
-People would like it.
People like it.
-Really?
[ Cheers and applause ]
People like this idea!
We could be onto something here.
-We could be onto something
here, because I would --
In fact, I loved --
Billy and I both took
singing lessons for this
'cause it -- not only was it
one of the hardest --
Sondheim is like, "Ugh!"
-Yeah.
-"No One's Going To Harm You,"
it's not the easiest, lyrically
or musically, to sing.
So, we had to --
thank God, a professional,
that we each spent
a couple of days with.
And I had so much fun
taking music -- singing lessons.
-It is fun.
-And so much, in fact,
a friend of mine actually
gifted me
with 10 singing lessons with
this said singing teacher.
So, I --
if I can get my act together,
maybe I would
even be in a musical.
-Wow!
All right.
Well, this is big.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a good present.
-This is big.
I mean,
we're just halfway through,
so why not start something
completely new?
-Yeah.
-Right?
-Can we talk about season two
of "The Morning Show"?
What's happening this season
with Alex?
-Oh, what's not happening, guys?
It's, uh --
It's pretty twisty, turny
couple of 10 episodes
you have ahead of you.
Well, we start out,
Alex has kind of removed herself
from the chaos that we left
at the end of season one
to sort of take stock,
inventory,
on what's it all about.
Alfie.
And then she gets
sucked back in my Mr. Crudup.
And, you know, I think she
believes she can take this
newfound wisdom and, you know,
self-realization
that she's gained with her
back into the TMS world,
but not so easy.
Not so fast.
-No.
-Each character goes through
some incredible twists and turns
and unexpected things.
Unimaginable things happen.
-Yeah.
You tackle some serious issues
in this show,
but I will say it's also
very humorous, as well.
There's funny parts of it.
-Yes.
-And there's relatable parts.
'Cause it's a morning show.
-Yes.
-So, anyways --
-Yeah.
Well, I mean, it's fun.
-Exactly.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Jennifer Aniston
in "The Morning Show."
Take a look at this.
-I can't come back.
Even if I wanted to come back,
I just couldn't.
I-I --
I would look flaky.
Wishy-washy.
-No, no, no, no.
When your new deal
got announced,
you looked smart as...
♪♪
-I don't want to.
I don't want to.
I'm done.
You know what, Cory?
I think it's --
I think you better go.
I mean,
you're not a horrible person.
I thoroughly enjoy you.
I mean, maybe you are actually
a horrible person,
but I still find you
entertaining.
You're a little --
You're a little crazy,
and it...scares me.
-Yeah! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys are fantastic together!
It is so good.
Jennifer Aniston, everybody!
The new season
of "The Morning Show"
is out on Apple TV+
starting today.